Being a citizen of the European Union
means that many aspects of our lives are
regulated by a weird entity.
It feels like a huge bureaucracy
is making decisions over our heads.
Many Europeans think that their vote
in the EU elections doesn't count than
that. The EU is not democratic.
How Democratic is the EU,
really?
And does your vote actually achieve
anything in democratic states?
Public policies are based
on the will of the people,
but the people are not a coherent thing.
Countless different groups are battling
for influence and power to establish
laws and rules that benefit
them. In a working democracy.
There are checks and balances that are
supposed to create a fair environment
where these battles can be fought,
term limits and stopped factions
from dominating too much.
But all of this ends at our borders.
International politics are
not democratic, but anoxic.
No central authority is powerful enough
to ensure fairness or enforced laws.
So the only law is the tyranny
of the strongest and anarchy.
So for most of human history,
powerful countries took what
they wanted from others,
either by extortion or by violence.
After World War Two the United Nations
were founded to overcome this anarchy by
establishing rules on how
countries should behave.
But since the UN has virtually no power
and its members often have opposing
interests, it's usually politely ignored.
The EU is a construct that tries to have
rules and laws for its member nations
that are actually enforceable as the
European Court of Justice is able to make
binding decisions.
Originally the EU was founded to ensure
peace between European nations and
prosperity for the continent,
but it's also an attempt to gain
international power for its members.
It's like a superstate and it's striving
to be democratic and legitimized by all
of its citizens. To do that,
it has to solve the problem of different
actors wanting different things.
Only that its members are countries
with very different priorities.
So how does this work?
Since the EU is ridiculously complex
and politicians are even worse than
scientists at naming,
things will simplify massively
and omit a lot of details.
You can find further reading
and explanations in our
sources document. Okay.
If you want to create a Democratic
Union of independent nations,
you have two options. One,
let everybody vote for
national politicians who
then make decisions for the
union together or to let every citizen
vote directly for an independent
institution that's able
to make binding decisions.
Both approaches have their upsides and
downsides and the EU ended up with a mix
of both of them. Next to the
European Court of Justice,
there are four main institutions
that we'll talk about today,
the European Council,
which is made up of the
heads of government or states
of the member countries,
the council of the EU with
ministers from the member countries.
The third one is the European Commission,
which is the de facto of government,
the EU having one commissioner
for each member state,
and lastly the European part of it.
The parliament is the only part of the
EU that is directly elected by you to
citizen in the European
elections. In principle,
all of these institutions of
the EU originate from your
direct or indirect vote,
be it at the national or EU level,
but some do more than others.
For example,
you vote for your national representative
and therefore contribute to form a
national government who's head of state
has a seat in the European Council.
These leaders choose the president
of the EU Commission and its fellow
commissioners who eventually are
confirmed by the EU parliament.
So this is a sort of indirect democracy.
You didn't vote for the commission,
but you voted for the people who appointed
them and for those who confirmed and
police them. So in effect,
2.5 of the four main European Union
institutions depend on the member state
governments,
but since you as a citizen can only
directly vote for the European Parliament,
the question is how powerful is it?
How much influence does your vote have?
The European Parliament started
out with very little influence,
but has become more and more powerful
over the past two decades or today.
It has to approve new laws, which can
be binding for the member countries.
It also votes on how the EU budget is
spent and on international treaties.
All of this makes the parliament
very powerful and thus your vote very
influential.
Even on an international level
compared to national parliaments,
one major power is still missing though
the EU parliament officially can't
propose new laws on its own, which
is often the core of the argument.
The EU is not democratic enough and that
the European Parliament should be given
more influence.
Right now the member states governments
pretty much control the European Union
giving the parliament more power would
make the EU as a whole more democratic,
but it would also take
power from member states.
It's not clear which approach is better.
Ultimately it's for the member states and
us as citizens to decide how the union
should develop. Okay,
so can we draw a
conclusion here as a whole?
The EU is not as democratic
as most of its member states,
but it is democratic.
If you don't like decisions they
make regarding copyright for example,
you can look up what your representatives
voted for and vote them out.
The struggle to make it more democratic
is closely tied to who holds power over
what the EU keeps changing.
You dare citizen an not only
voting on the current politics,
but also on what system will
look like in the future.
There are many parties and politicians
that vow to make the EU parliament and
therefore your vote stronger.
Many others want to keep it
as it is or even diminish it.
It's for you to decide what you think
is better for the future of the union.
Currently,
it's equally important for the EU who you
vote for at home because these are the
people who have the most influence
in the European Union right now.
Opinion at home is also where the
EU is often used as a scapegoat.
Politicians, especially
before national elections,
liked to pretend the EU is all powerful
and mix up rules and laws of the heads
of the governments and citizens,
although often they were directly
responsible for what the EU did.
Democracy is annoying and complicated
enough and very boring in the European
Union even more so than
in the member states,
but voting and caring about
how our political institutions
change and develop is
one of the most powerful
things we can do as citizens.
The last few years have shown that
extreme thing was can happen through
elections.
We have to decide if we want to
be an active part of this process.
If we don't take part in the struggle for
power, that is politics. Others, well,
and we might not like what they decide
for us because Europe is an important
topic for us.
We've translated this video into as
many European languages as possible.
A couple of European youtube isn't
aerated is and uploaded it to their own
channels. Thank you to funk and
all youtube ers who helped us.
You can find a playlist with all
language versions in the description
[inaudible].